In the previous video, we only
used one independent variable,
but there are many
different variables
that could be used to
predict wine price.
We used average growing
season temperature,
but we also have data for other
weather-related variables--
harvest rain and winter rain.
Additionally, the age of wine
is suspected to be important,
and many other
variables could also
be used, such as the
population of France.
We can use each variable in a
one variable regression model.
Average growing
season temperature
gives the best R squared of
0.44, followed by harvest rain
within R squared of 0.32.
France's population
and age, both
give models within R
squared around 0.2,
and winter rain gives a
pretty low R squared of 0.02,
or just barely better
than the baseline.
So if we only used one
variable, average growing season
temperature is the best choice.
But multiple linear
regression allows
you to use multiple variables
at once to improve the model.
The multiple linear
regression model
is similar to the one
variable regression
model that has a
coefficient beta
for each independent variable.
We predict the
dependent variable y
using the independent
variables x1, x2, through xk,
where k here denotes the
number of independent variables
in our model.
Beta 0 is, again,
the coefficient
for our intercept term, and
beta 1, beta 2, through beta k
are the coefficients for
the independent variables.
We use i to denote the data
for a particular data point
or observation.
The best model is selected
in the same way as before.
To minimize the sum of squared
errors, using the error terms,
epsilon.
We can start by building a
linear regression model that
just uses the variable with
the best R squared-- average
growing season temperature.
We saw before that this gives
us an R squared of 0.44.
Then we can add
variables one at a time
and look at the
improvement in R squared.
Note that the improvement is
not equal to the one variable
R squared for each
independent variable we add,
since they're interactions
between the independent
variables.
Adding independent
variables improves
the R squared to
almost double what
it was with a single
independent variable.
But there are
diminishing returns.
The marginal improvement from
adding an additional variable
decreases as we add
more and more variables.
So which model should we use?
Often not all variable
should be used.
This is because each additional
variable used requires
more data, and
using more variables
creates a more
complicated model.
Overly complicated
models often cause
what's known as overfitting.
This is when you have
a higher R squared
on data used to
create the model,
but bad performance
on unseen data.
For example, suppose we
want to use this model
to make a prediction
for the year 2013.
We expect an overfit
model to perform poorly
on this new data.
In the next video, we'll learn
how to build a regression
models in R and
then we'll discuss
how to select the
variables that should
be included in the final model.